[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm a world famous comedian you're
welcome I really shouldn't be here
um but we're gonna have some dates uh
please sign up we got the lgbtqia plus
bucket looking real a
for asexual if you know what I mean
this is balance America we have a couple
more people to be queer tonight
we're gonna Force someone
just like Joe Biden would have wanted
can we get the lights a little bit
brighter up here let's let's really see
the acne scars on my face thank you are
you guys ready to see people date each
other tonight make some [ __ ] noise
clap woo
yeah whistle if you're Mexican
those goddamn Mexicans
they're always whistling you guys ever
go to Home Depot am I the only one
uh we're gonna have fun even if there
are Mexicans here we're gonna pretend
like they're white
I'm just kidding I'm being racist as a
joke
um we are gonna have two people come up
one person's gonna come up we're gonna
get to know them and then we're gonna
draw another name they're gonna go on a
date for 90 seconds
and then we're gonna interview them and
talk to them find out why they said the
things that they said
and what they're doing here
are you guys ready for that
hell yeah we got a guest very funny guy
he is half asian we got a little bit of
the Asian persuasion on stage tonight
give it up for Michael Ridley
hey Michael how you feeling tonight
whoa sounds like a sex crime
there's so many sexy people in here okay
don't point at the ones that you think
are sexy
um but yeah what uh what What's your
dating situation right now oh [ __ ]
okay he's off the table ladies
oh so he's single
in Austin
what do you miss the most about her
oh you guys uh
you guys twerk together
yeah
he's coming in his laundry it's
that's a discouraging reminder for us
Asian men
sex
it's a hate crime
well it's not all about Asians and our
sex life on this show we are here to see
other people dating let's get our first
contestant up here we got a straight
female all two of them
everyone's asexual tonight
please sign up we need you straight
women we got Audrey Jack coming up
Audrey Jack give it up for Audrey Jack
where is Audrey Jack we need you
literally you're the only person
we need right now we have plenty of
dudes
Bros
Audrey Jack
she's on oh you signed her up
then why are we looking around you know
she's not here
what the [ __ ]
Amy R in the house here she comes the
hero of the night it's Amy r
just gonna make your dick [ __ ]
that's a thought that's what the r
stands for
um
our word coming up
hello Amy r
how are you doing tonight
yeah it's kind of show show business
is it on
all right
what do you
you are this there's another person her
friend you're the only person you're the
only person that signed up on time
is that Audrey r or
Audrey J there she is late
[ __ ]
don't uh trust her to take the morning
after pill because she'll be probably
late for that too
IUD hell yeah that's for the lazy
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
well I think God is making an IED joke
God is uh
fighting insurgents in Iraq
um but yeah IUD for lazy [ __ ]
we got uh Amy R here Amy what are you
looking for in a date tonight
so you're just looking for a quick [ __ ]
she's looking for
someone that's gonna give her a great
lake
enter I don't know what I'm saying I'm
sorry I apologize to women
that's my cousin's name too
we can both make these jokes
all two billion of us
oh this we need this well Amy R you're
in luck it's a buyer's market out here
for dick
so you get the pick of the litter
tonight
we got Chad o in the building
give it up for Chad oh
here he comes in his fancy motorcycle
jacket
he's ready to room right to your heart
90 seconds of dating starting now
okay
okay
I've been there before
I just moved here in August
uh it's not his jacket whether it's a
dog
oh well it's warmer yeah
thank you
which isn't playing too well today okay
I'm trying
oh
someone's younger
um
[Music]
this is a great conversation
I think he gives us too much time now he
should be sitting something like
everyone's boring yeah what are they
even talking about
it really is it's like just a little
dull like what do you like what kind of
food do you like
and time give it up for a chat oh and
AVR
[Applause]
going with the age-old classic what's
your favorite food we all have to eat
so Amy are you have a boyfriend in
Chicago
are you a brother okay
nice yes
[Music]
and by brother do you mean a large
African-American gentleman or
back in Iraq
that's awesome
good job Chad you uh complimented your
dates boy uh brother this is a good move
you don't see him as a threat
we're not in Alabama after all
Chad what do you know about Chicago
whoa you should have brought that up
all right let's get to food
[Music]
you got that weird-ass pizza that's true
it's backwards that satanic thick ass
Pizza y'all be eating out there okay
people think that's like a thing
okay good yeah it is
for Taurus yes
nice
what do you think about that weird
little mayor you guys have
a good idea
what if uh
if she was our man there'd be more
people in the lgbtqia plus bucket
[Music]
fortunately we just have whoever the
[ __ ] we elected Greg Abbott
yeah more politics yeah what is the uh
wheelchair
the wheelchair people and the
um
[Music]
shadow
what uh what do you think about politics
well luckily you're on both politics
no way
you have the jacket as someone that
doesn't vote
yeah
I was gonna say it was a reply to me
so obviously I read why
can I get it not a blue flag and a red
flag
what are you guys do you guys are
pulling your name out of the bucket
gonna be on stage the whole night you
know
uh Amy R what uh what what do you think
about politics
boats
[Music]
you know I think everybody concerts
already
like if someone's like do you have a
profile says no
not
foreign
[Music]
politics uh when did you get vaccinated
are you boosted
you look like your boosted you sound
like you're boosted
uh that's cool Chad are you uh boosted
uh
it's a smart move
refuse
refuse free medicine
okay
so you're an Uber delivery driver
[Music]
nice so uh how does that usually go on a
date when you bring that up I go hey uh
nice what do you think Michael
I think that's the kind of person that I
would angrily argue with ubereats chat
about it
meanwhile there's someone else on the
other screen going no it's different
told me away
it's on the way Amar uh have you ever
had any funny Uber stories
there are no door handles and
there's
oh God
he's only delivering food
[Music]
well uh how do you like Austin we don't
have a train system as complex as
Chicago but we do have bird scooters
here
honestly no I love the scooters we live
in Chicago too but they started taking
them away I don't know if it was like
yeah here Governor Abbott made sure
we're all on wheels
the Texas way too many drive-by scooter
shootings in Chicago
it's hard to do it with one hand
have you ever been paddle boarding in
Austin
yes January is a perfect time to get on
the lake
oh wait no paddleberry
no we like to live dangerously here in
Austin
no walls
Chad where do you take dates
how does that usually go
oh you only date when you're on stage
here
[Music]
it's very sad for me you're in the chat
in this equation
yeah there needs to be another panel on
that Meme for the Hans
Chad
sorry to out chat a chad
it's the American dream an Asian man has
never achieved that status before
Amy have you ever dated an Asian man
before
he goes
you don't think so have you ever like
had a one night stand with one
okay then you haven't dated ever
there's a billion of us
there's a billion of us that means you
went out of your way to not date us and
very offended
by now
yeah it barely feels like anything
sorry guys
we need a whiteboard
Chad have you ever dated an Asian woman
before or a man
I'm Filipino or maybe on the [ __ ]
culture out there
[Music]
and we were making fun of them
Filipinos making white men feel weird
since the 60s
Amy uh have you ever met a Filipino
before
and how much money did they take from
you
you're from Chicago aren't you used to
this where is your money at
honestly what three cars
okay don't just free associate please
answer the questions that are asked of
you
Chad shut the [ __ ] up dude
Amy so uh where in Chicago do you live
oh sounds really white
[Music]
nice
okay
Leroy
areas are like really really white it's
like
Lincoln Park oh yeah that sounds really
white though because
it's a band that all white people like
half of Michael Ridley's got a boner
right now
that's more Chicago than Amy R is speed
Chester
Chester benningfield
killed himself
yep
uh Amy
huh
no she's not from Lincoln Park
Amy uh what kind of music are you into
a lot of uh
a lot of One Direction
[Music]
okay
Chad what kind of music are you into and
how much screaming is in it
yep he needs some support especially
from people that look like Jews
yep it's the money Amy would you like to
go on another date tonight
you have someone
else
there's only one other person they're
gonna get a chance at halftime
yeah someone's gotta sign up to save Amy
R from this
autism Olympics
we need a real chat up here
Chad what's the uh chattis thing that
you've done
well you're gonna fly a plane
hopefully you don't steer right into the
ground like this date
we went on a date
Amy would you like to go out one more
date please
she said no okay get the [ __ ] out of
here then
we're gonna make some straight men gay
that's always uh Audrey Jack that's you
I'm giving my nomination to her no
that's not her name your name is Audrey
Jack
you showed up late
[Music]
we're gonna get a
get him a straight man named Ahmed
oh my God
this guy is really eager to [ __ ] his own
girlfriend
[Music]
90 seconds from this old married couple
give it up for
uh Jack and Audrey Jack and Ahmet
clap for Audrey Jack and Ahmed
[Applause]
[Music]
we have 90 seconds
[Music]
um
[Music]
I went into thinking I didn't want a
boyfriend so very interesting so yeah
okay so I'm just gonna do conventional
replies to your questions okay so you're
from Milwaukee while it looks like
cheese I love cheese I love cheese I
love cheese but I hate beer oh me too I
don't like beer either really wow yeah
wow we have so much fun we do me too
where are you from
um I'm originally from Arizona
you look like a specific like ethnicity
though I'm accepting something really
helpful why we have no interesting
country that you're from now who you're
attached to oh well I am albanians no
way wait my family's Albanian yes
uh okay cool so what do you like to do
on the weekends well I'd love to go
mountain biking and time give it up for
Audrey Jack and Ahmed
the kissing cousins
is that something they do in South
Albania the Alabama
oh that's how it is in England
Halloween
how long have you guys been on only fans
[Music]
let's go on vacation we made 150 000
this year and [ __ ] in my parents
house
you seem like you've seen their videos
yeah maybe yeah
Ali cousins
you guys look like a hinge commercial
hahaha
we've been in a club
you said you love cheese but hate beer
and I heard half the Crowd Goes deathly
silent
a lot of beer fans half of them work in
breweries on the east side
this is the biggest
[Music]
yes
because they're not poor hahaha
[Laughter]
so how's uh how's Texas treating you
Midwestern all right
my two best friends who love signing up
for things are from Texas so we're out
here visiting them for the holidays oh
nice which one of them signs you up
symbol
[Applause]
nice
thank you
yeah I love the sorority energy you're
bringing
no way
well you signed up your friend which
means by the bylaws of other people you
are going on the next date so
[Applause]
please do not sign up people that are
not yourself
wow
symbol has a boyfriend so we're gonna
try to ruin that relationship tonight
we're gonna video record it and send it
to him
[Applause]
uh so
okay well we'll figure it out later
um you guys are cousins from Milwaukee
hate beer uh
so uh Ahmed are you uh am I saying that
right yeah
[Music]
that's my dream is to be white
Starbucks gives you guys slave names
[Applause]
kind of scary
you know
so how did you like Starbucks you met a
lot of people that look like your
girlfriend
so what I mean by Starbucks then is that
like when I order a drink I tell them my
name is Matt I never actually work for
Starbucks oh you just
know where Albania is
um
I'm half white I don't know much
I didn't know either before
did it just say you were Albanian yeah I
was lying oh okay
something
[Music]
nice yeah I know what Albania is it's
right between the two Wars that's always
going on in that region of the world
importance or assault rifles and
children
yeah that's another one Andrew take got
arrested
Romania
you got arrested in Ania
[Music]
my name is my name is Matt
do you want some blood
I like how Audrey your parents named you
after your actual Starbucks name they
were like
We're not gonna have her translate
anything she's gonna be perfectly
fitting into the White Society
the whole the whole Starbucks stands up
sure Philippines Korea so what's your uh
yeah uh
Milwaukee Chicago
so what's your favorite position
[Music]
she is the prince who else
oh yeah so you guys just make out the
whole night
I'm saving myself
what kind of Albanian is with the Virgin
gosh you got your Albanian
[Music]
it's not it's the opposite you're like a
virgin
um but yeah when's the first time you
had sex
oh
you were mostly in a bomb shelter hiding
from the war
so fun fact is
for bomb shelters and
so we have about three million people
and there's like three points in the
bomb shelters it's a great way
so that's why you didn't [ __ ]
everyone's everyone's in their virgin
Chambers
[Music]
uh Audrey Jack what was your sorority
like
[Music]
but it's a really fun story yeah
you guys know that they like have to
sacrifice blood no this is a real thing
like period blood
apparently I'm not supposed to say this
machine oh yeah everyone
's
some shut up
everyone's dying to know the secrets of
Pi beta feta or whatever
no one gives a [ __ ] about sororities
okay it's only this fraternities where
they like jerk off in the Geronimo skull
that we care about
because men control the world okay
any uh crazy culty things happen there
[Music]
any anything like that happened
that happens
it was going on
it was hazy because of the roofing that
your boyfriend put in your drink
yeah he just
was the Albanian kidnappings to get his
girlfriend uh
ski masks
AK-47s
[Music]
that wasn't a perfect combination he's
been in gun loving places his whole life
Albania Texas
Arizona what I was also Marine but I do
not which country
uh I fought for
eign
no one's in a sorority no one's in the
military
[Music]
we're all independent free thinkers
we all love cocaine too much
to be in the military
surprised more people are in the
sororities
um but yeah that's cool so uh what's
your favorite kind of gun and when have
you ever used it
the year that albanians got freedom
holy [ __ ]
well I'm sorry man I didn't realize
[Music]
okay that's the wrong thing to say
pissing off people with guns
[Music]
go back into bomb shelter
so how much do you love Bill Clinton
over there
uh what a what a chad
thank you
Audrey do you want to hunt the homeless
for sport too or
[Applause]
anyways
well uh any any last questions for this
wonderful couple that's already in a
relationship together
[Music]
Island bucket that you and eight other
women have to be in today
give it up for Albanian Andrew Tate
and it's victim Audrey Jack
[Laughter]
this is the part of the show where we
get two guys to [ __ ] each other
that's all we have left
oh my God he just kidnapped her
only fans guys
he's all limbs this guy
we got a man named Bernard White's
coming up give it up for Bernard whites
[Applause]
we're gonna get to know a little bit
more about Bernard white a large black
man
and if any women want to sign up you get
a free shot
of alcohol I know this [ __ ] is like
what
that's how much it costs
Bernard whites how are you doing tonight
what do you look for in uh
uh date slash victim
Stoner are you a big stoner
yes
he's wearing a Mr THC shirt
what's the highest you've ever been
haha
you've been so high that you want to go
to a store and you got into your car and
a police car pulled by and then you're
stuck in that car for like 90 minutes
just waiting for those invisible GTA
stars and stopped flashing exactly
exactly
well you know you are also black which
[Applause]
close my eyes
my eyes you have a very unique
experience
um what's it like dating in Austin
horrible oh
well
that's all about to change tonight
because
we're
gonna get you laid
we got uh one of these ladies coming up
[Applause]
you you did sign up you did sign up your
friend Audrey Jack out of nowhere and
she wasn't even here kind of
but uh yeah we'll we'll save you guys
we'll put you in the pocket you'll be
pinch headers you know if a lady you
know needs to go to the bathroom or you
know you know how they do that they go
to the bathroom
y'all
crazy uh Bernard what uh what do you
think is your most attractive attribute
my ability to listen and understand
okay
that was fine as well is that just what
happens when you smoke too much weed
yes
it was a natural listener
we are looking for a day for Bernard
white and I would hate to have to make
him date a dude that is a sex crime so
any women in the audience want to go on
a date tonight
come on up here we got Bernard whites
very sexy man he is a good listener
he is also
very prudent about not getting arrested
she's coming on up here
thank you
she's only coming here for the free weed
90 seconds of dating with a hero lady
and Bernard white starting now
for a long time
I was there for a year
Southwest
okay okay
that's right uh so uh what do you do
I'm such a worker ah
I have no questions about that at all
either yeah
it's like what child's we've taken from
people so far
CPS but I get it
what do you do
um I do voice work apps and uh
randomlying stuff you do stand up I
actually
people yeah
so you stand up too okay
all right fair enough
see Mr THC the high Canadian there you
go
so are you from Austin yes I've been
here for 33 years wow
wow what motivated me
I got laid off from my job retired laid
off whatever
friend actually a number in with her and
I did
and time give it up for Bernard white
and Sam
[Applause]
Bernard white yeah a friend asked you to
move in with her
yeah she did was it sexual in nature
hell yeah Bernard white you're acting
like you're so sad about dating you're
you're getting like free room and board
and sex
that is tough to do
that's what the social worker is trying
to get the rest of Austin
come back Michael
you missed this wonderful chemistry we
had
no I heard
oh nice
[Music]
Bernard's like I've never taken a little
pee pee
it's an Asian man thing
that's the Asian way
uh Sam what uh what do you think about
Austin and the dating scene here
it's horrible disgusting
and you're not even black
the cops cops aren't even trying to
arrest you
have you ever been arrested
wow
there's always a start somewhere so
those tattoos are all done in a
professional setting
I'm sorry behind that little [ __ ] up
each town until you drown
looks like a stamp you get at a club
what was it supposed to say
S I [ __ ] up
because everything
that's cool we're all 18 once
um Bernard what's the uh craziest tattoo
that you have
nice this Temple that's full of weed
so with the T and THC stands for
um
okay yeah
have you uh
you're gonna just get those uh Myrtle
Beach t-shirts
have you ever gotten any [ __ ] from
looking like a civil rights hero
nice
are you sure she are you sure she just
didn't have cancer
how did like yo I'm pretty sure that
girl has cancer dogs
[Laughter]
do you know what Caillou is
yes okay you're one of those black
people
the ones that uh
yeah how dare you how dare you call all
Asians children
uh that's cool so uh yeah you uh
you you did that
how's the uh how's the skinhead [ __ ]
interesting
interesting
vocal do you mean like racial slurs
oh my God
well
yeah
how did you how did you first find out
she was a skinhead
[Music]
you're like okay let's go to my place
all right I'll prove you wrong
no no I'll prove you wrong
they got lady white supremacists out
there that's the thing go and get some
bald races [ __ ] down in San Antonio
yeah you proved her wrong you're like I
might be an N word but my dick is Tiny
all right I'm sorry
well that's cool you uh did you convert
or did you save her
Maybe
I thought for a Nazi she'd be more into
numbering people minorities
yeah
uh Sam have you ever dated a racist
how are you gonna convert them if you
never date them
what's like a big red flag to you
[Music]
Audrey Jack you're out
what are your red flags
um
too many mind changes too many like
Choice changes too many like
explanations on things that make no
sense
yeah that's why you're single that's
just me
yeah I think you're into dudes man
[Music]
Amy's got it figured out dude they're
like yo let's play basketball [ __ ] dude
[Music]
Bernard do you uh ever play basketball
and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
football like uh tackle
people
that's cool
Sam uh what kind of guys are you
normally into
[Music]
um
[Music]
working towards at least working towards
Financial stability damn dude that's
that's how you know it's hard to date
like it just kept going lower
and what a burger then yeah you might
get the [ __ ] remember yeah
ability
so have you ever met someone like that
or is this just a pipe dream
[Music]
what's the latest a guy has ever been
30 minutes I told him don't even come
I'll believe you and then he put his
pants on his leg
s
Bernard is there anything you'd like to
say about your punctuality to Sam
you can't get rid of this guy
no
what's your what's your go-to move on a
date
a big old sigh
s
want smoke you want some shrooms
you're saying all the right things Sam
is nodding vigorously
do you partake no I don't smoke I don't
drink you've never been to jail you just
have those tattoos you're sending the
wrong message to everyone
never done psychedelics or nothing no
wow your brain sucks
you'd scream and go to jail
that's crazy so you've never done drugs
and you're just always waiting for
people to show up on time
just sober as [ __ ]
what what is psychotro is that some
white people [ __ ]
breathing exercises
got my yoga mat out
what is it it's like
meds
oh hell yeah this girl's like
I don't know I drove from West Virginia
oxycodone
hell yeah that's cool Bernard actually
is the more uh respectable drug user
among the two of you I wouldn't have
guessed
Bernard if you're trying to convince
someone to smoke weed how would you go
about doing it
[Music]
the surprise gummy
nice even for the racist skinhead
s
nice and did she become less racist
once you got high
oh
wow you'd think she would hate white
people more for her horrible life
[Music]
oh okay that's not that bad then
it just isn't a word for white people
Sam have you ever dated outside of your
race
[Music]
you've only had one relationship that's
very 20 22 of you
have you ever been in an open
relationship
well
you did when I first saw you but then
you kept talking about how sober you are
like if you don't like drugs you
probably stick with one dude that's
enough stimulation for any sober person
so uh yeah you've been a lot of uh
situationships what is usually the uh
deal breaker in these situationships
oh they can't find the [ __ ]
[Music]
in my face
I love your impression of me it's yeah
I'm having a client
hahaha
you can't really tell when you're happy
you always look happy you got like the
permanent Buddha face
is our Jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you've never seen that yeah okay there
we go yeah oh yeah the Multicultural
Audrey Jack over there
Eastern European and Asian cultures
em what do you uh what do you think
about uh doing weed for the first time
what what kind of situation would it
have to be
unfortunately wow
exactly how I started Audrey jacks
Audrey Jack's boyfriend's gonna kidnap
you and
make you do some coerced fun
that's cool so you wouldn't you wouldn't
really do it unless there was like a
mid-summer situation it's like a white
festival
South by Southwest
how old are you
oh my God
you're old
I'm 33.
I didn't mean to say you're old I meant
just like I would think by 28 you would
have taken a puff
s
[Music]
[Applause]
he's from Virginia
times like
oh yeah and then I was like all those
people are crazy it's like I'm as boring
as I am they were just turned off to it
by your childhood
cocaine in our house growing up that's a
fun job yeah like I had a Mexican
stepdad that I bonded within the cocaine
it was actually full Asian when he was
born and then
Bernard would you ever do cocaine
I'm 43 years old I've done a lot of
cocaine in my life
well give it up for Bernard Wyatt and
Sam they went on a date together
thank you so much for coming up here Sam
she's a hero a brave brave woman the
Harriet Tubman of
Austin Texas
[ __ ] all these Tech weirdos well we
do have to have one of you ladies come
up Audrey which one which one of your
friends do you nominate Simone
Simone Simone up here
yeah
we're very reluctant Simone biles
she's a gymnast
or as the name of one
uh we're gonna get to know Simone a
little bit
Simon Simon oh gosh you guys are all
Albanian
Simon how are you tonight
what brings you out to other people the
comedy dating show
you're some coerced fun bye the
albanians
so uh what are you looking for in a date
you're single
oh
oh you you don't want a woman
oh man I thought we're gonna have our
first lesbian date
you can date your friend
oh
well that's fun so you're not really
looking you're just having fun being
single
situationships
oh you're like you're like Sam but with
dick
[Music]
s
Milwaukee
why don't you just say Milwaukee
it's the only city in Wisconsin anyone
gives a [ __ ] about
yeah for college kids
Manitowoc that's where that guy got
arrested Stephen Avery making a murder
um we got Green Bay
anyways this lady knows nothing about
the state she's from
we're just inside just not [ __ ]
what was the last relationship you were
in what happened there
[Music]
oh yeah it's a Wisconsin tradition
so Wisconsin Divorce Court
uh that's cool so who against who did
you restrain him or did he restrain you
oh okay yeah go way to go female power
um what she's clapping for a restraining
order
Milwaukee
so
yes
at least he had a phone
is
and then he would like call me from
random numbers nice dude oh this is so
bad
well luckily you're in Texas now away
from all those cold frigid [ __ ]
all their dicks are tiny they're sad
about it because how cold it is
um
unlike Texas
a bunch of Asian hunks in Texas
dudes in here
bucket full of dicks we got one name we
got Nicholas sapaglia coming up
give it up to the set Meister General
he's gonna go on a date with Simone
saman Simone
Wisconsin native
Texas transplant
go on a date with a beautiful Nick
sapaglia give it up for them one more
time
[Applause]
so what are you doing
sounds good
here
okay
give me Place 11. give me a microphone
man
give me
just to group home
do you like Austin so far so far yeah
that's nice I've never left California
before
comedy
how do you like it
it's
a lot of insurance
they don't really have breathing suit
and so I'm noticed
excuse me I've never I didn't notice
that yeah
every time I go to a Mexican restaurant
order burrito they give me like a giant
Taco that's just laid down with a bunch
of like sauce on it like this is not a
burrito
foreign
[Applause]
wow white guy from Fresno telling Austin
how to make Mexican food
[Music]
that was almost as stupid as a guy that
says he hated guns in Texas
so what's the uh Fresno Mexican food
situation like
very good wow
just
no burritos
are you just trying to make a pitch for
your giant burrito [ __ ]
you're gonna
get
we're all friends here
yeah thank you man this is a charity
charity he's doing charity for me it's
text right right off uh you were
surprised that Simon did not want to
live in Fresno do you realize that most
people do not want to live in Fresno
right
yeah she was like I was gonna go to
Fresno you're like oh you're gonna live
there she's like no
no
well now she's here in a real State full
of freedoms
what what is your favorite Freedom that
you have that you don't have here that
you don't have in California
[Music]
you're from Fresno that's like the most
Wisconsin part of Texas California
yeah but it's still a bunch of levels uh
too many that's why you moved to Austin
oh nice it's good to know uh Simone what
do you think about liberals
wow
what do you think about masks
your I mean
nothing was necessary
oh my God I know you were in antifa
Jesus
um very cool guy you know Nick sapaglia
very chill energy you're never gonna
need a restraining order for him
you're gonna need a get out of bed order
what's the craziest loudest that you've
ever been Nick
foreign
what a quiet little boy
well like do you go to festivals
[Music]
that sounds perfect for you Simon you're
a liberal
do you ever go to
yeah
so uh you think where do you think Nick
would be best at to take on a date
like a library
yeah maybe you could sign him up for
things that he didn't want to do like
your friend Audrey Jack
dear
hell yeah
Michael Ridley's mullet just grew three
inches longer
[Applause]
so how do you know these uh wonderful
group of people that you came here with
[Music]
in Milwaukee
and
she uh she knew Audrey before the
Albanian
how how was she uh different before the
kidnapping and after
oh
taken seven
just hearing about
this
I was concerned when he showed up and
put his feet on the stage
don't be to walk on your territory you
didn't walk
just lounged on it
the Albanian way it just needs a track
suit and it'll be super comfortable
nick uh have you ever dated uh whatever
a Simone is
Mexican
I guess they don't have Mexicans in
Wisconsin
imagine how bad their burritos are in
Wisconsin
[Music]
whoa
she's one of us
oh Pakistan
is it
okay he drove on an island
what does that mean it shows
what should I be like living in a hood
in the dirt did you see that about me
anyone sticks into it
well you know I follow you on Instagram
so I've seen your Hut it's a sick Hut
CH is it a Pizza Hut
is it all right moving forward uh
you guys are really chill
who is really comfortable with each
other
they got Pakistan and Fresno in the
house
we got domestic terrorists and regular
terrorists
uh Nick what would you take Simone on a
date
I'll probably take you to maybe like
Terry Boston's barbecue and if you
haven't been there yet it's a good place
to check out it's pretty popular around
here shit's expensive
side corn is like 15 bucks
whoa that was quick did you hear that
what an agreeable
nice man
uh have you ever been on a date with a
nice guy
and
how did you reject him
[Music]
okay
doorbell are you the racist guy that
Bernard white [ __ ]
a racist woman
thank God
Nick what's the most racist person that
you had sex with
um
foreign
you were fascinated by the food trucks
out here in Austin
do you uh is that because you're from
Pakistan you're not used to normal
restaurants
I'm sorry that was racist
um what's uh what kind of food do you
like to get at food trucks
no burritos
that's cool do you do you do drugs as
well
yeah Sam take that Sam
what's your favorite drug
gosh your Pakistani but you're white as
[ __ ]
you would love to go on some of the
festivals that Nick goes to
that's fine
yeah the security as a Pakistani to get
into large Gatherings is insane
uh
but yeah you're uh you don't look
Pakistani so
like Indians
[Music]
well we're not just here to make fun of
Pakistani Nick is white uh
[Music]
what's the widest thing that you've done
recently
go to music festivals
have you ever driven by a cop and didn't
even notice there was a cop there
hell yeah you are a cop aren't you okay
um but yeah any uh anything you want to
say to this Fresno meets Wisconsin
couple
white trash Central
[Music]
I feel like you guys smoking we're two
condoms
that's how bland
well give it up for Simone and dexta
Paglia
two condom couple
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out
we got Michael Ridley here give it up
for Michael Ridley [ __ ] sweat
[Applause]
what did you think any any last words
yeah chorus fun
yeah
it's a big city get her to date the
Albanian free her from the kidnapping
situation
get Sam to do drugs
and Bernard white to uh you know
wear a white mask when you drive or
something
uh but that was a show thank you guys so
much for coming out watching dates and
racism all at the same time my name is
Hans Kim drive safe good night
[Applause]